hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to super nanny sleepy time
Ultra HD alpha-omega
that's the name of the game I've
actually been playing it for a while
already this game uh long in the short
I'm gonna be totally honest with you
I'm not gonna try to sugarcoat this in
any way we're beating small children and
I don't know if you have any any uh any
opinions on the ethics of beating small
children but we're just trying to beat
him to sleep we're not trying to like
kill him or anything it's for their own
good we're just trying to we're just
trying to make him go to bed you know
it's it's it's a rough life being in a
nanny so you need actually like when
they're spitballing yeah and jumping on
your face and all you didn't seem to
whack them in the balls with a pillow
whack him in the face with a pillow
don't whack small children is generally
the life lesson leave that to the video
games of the world so anyway with this
game you're playing a nanny and you're
not very good at your job but you do it
efficiently and getting everyone into
bed and making sure that they disappear
and some strange fasten so there's
really not much else to say about it you
just beautiful children it's oddly fun I
don't know why it is this doesn't say
anything about my personality right this
this is not a personality test I'm not
gonna be judged by this only a few
million people are probably gonna watch
this
no one's gonna think I'm a horrible
person for enjoying this right bashing
little kids in the face with a pillow
no no but into the sleep of the pillow
oh god it sounds so bad
ah I wasn't paying attention oh I did
horribly hang on I can do better than
that one second Luther hair well you
bastard kids yeah for me oh he's dead
okay seems awfully violent for a
babysitting game gonna care go to kid
you bastard beds okay you want some
wants a face full of murder I'm not
gonna kill you kids I'm just gonna beat
you till you're unconscious I doesn't
sound any better
I'm just gonna murder your face with
this pillow I mean that doesn't sound it
actually that sounds straight up like
I'm gonna murder you I'm gonna smother
you did that in your sleep
well they're gone and they look so happy
when they're flying off to their doom I
mean I'm not gonna ignore the fact that
they're disappearing once they go on
those beds this is a Neverland Peter Pan
that I don't want any part of come
on camp got about camp goin about camp
I'm gonna pretend like I'm not dying is
hardly fun considering what I'm doing
which is beating small children but hey
I'm a nanny
that's like allowed right I'm not sure
what I'm doing is legal I'm not sure
what I'm doing is legal oh I mean I'm
assuming that well I mean the only
reason that there would be like this
many children in one place is if this is
an orphanage and in that regard I'm even
worse I'm beating up orphans why
horribly it's a hard-knock life for you
I'm gonna pee in the face with the
pillow and then you're gonna go to sleep
for a while then disappear hole cut this
song is dark I don't remember this party
Annie it's really sad because obviously
their only possession of these spitballs
in these paper hats that they made
probably their clothes aren't even close
they're just by a radioactive Factory
they just grew that color on their skin
oh that's so sad not true probably
probably I don't know cuz I'm gonna go
to bed kids is that what they're saying
probably Oh Oh my stress is getting a
little high too many spit ballers skin
Mads getting bad getting is getting
dicey getting dicey here gettin Tyson
here oh crap I'm going for the high
score but I don't think I'm gonna good
job y'all yeah wow that was a big combo
but still doing badly with the stress
levels
oh crap on my dime a dime and I died I
died I gonna get
oh man this is surprisingly difficult
who woulda thought this was gonna be
difficult oh crap I must be really good
at what I'm noon ah guess the perches in
horrible ways there's a lot of children
Chris what's pumping out all this
children this actually a baby factory
and I'm just taking care of the rejects
oh so sad I'm glad that you know in the
grand world of gaming there there's
there's games that represent all facets
of life like oh no like death horrible
deserve a death aw man I don't even know
what my score was what was my score
Holden pay attention it's true busy
peaking small children all right this
time I'm really gonna go for a high
score here I think the high score is
like to get on the leaderboard it's like
8000 this is all part of the game Joel
game jam that I'm a part of and you can
play this game too and I highly
encourage you to it's actually really
fun so try to beat my high score when
you do play it because oddly strange bit
of fun here not gonna lie sounds like go
to band camp which I don't recommend I
went to band camp once it was horrible
this one time in band camp is that what
this is this band camp one time at band
camp nothing bad happened I just put a
lot of children to sleep uh-huh I'm not
a member
there's no either this game looks good
for me because I'm laughing blankly as I
beat small humans tiny itty-bitty
defenseless humans I'm in the hour
trying to murder me on assume I mean
with their spit balls and their hugs how
dare you hug me I'm the super nanny top
it for bed hugs are punishable by death
other than that it actually is a really
fun game to play I will I will openly
admit it's it's really fun I mean it's
simple like this whole game jam it's
about games that were made in a short
period of time and there's actually
hundreds of games up on gamejolt
right now that you guys can play and
vote on to try to decide what the good
one is I think this one got like third
place or something it did really well
and obviously it's a well made game for
being made in such a short time fun idea
fine idea
questionable on the ethics a fun idea oh
okay my stress is climbing a bit I need
to get my stress down there we go
that's better I just need to get the
combos on the bashing the children in
the face yeah that's good
there we go that's it that's the good
stuff I don't know if it's good stuff I
don't know if anything's could be
qualified as the good stuff here because
so many questions where am I
what orphanarium loves to do this like
what our venereum allows this they're
not called orphan errand sister feature
feature out McCullum they're called
orphanages or orphan ages or Vantage's
no no ha damn at six three sir
I was close I was close to making it on
the board damn it damn it I want to make
it on the board dammit dammit dammit
dude badges Batman's bathroom again too
many kids do it again do it again no I
didn't even get close that time okay so
the best second dude was like six
thousand seven hundred something so if
you can beat that wash me to it or let
me watch you do it let me watch you wow
I don't think this episode could have
been any more creeper but thank you all
so much for watching check out the link
in the description below for this game
and check out the other cool games in
the game jam right now there's a ton of
them there and they're all high score
based so try to get on the leaderboard
here thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video I talk of a door before
you go in one of them
let it break on three boobs ugly woman
half is good right